the left-wing mainstream media just
cannot believe that President Trump
received a clean bill of health
something that would be good from his
physician and now they're looking for
any excuse to discredit the results
beyond pathetic take a look what he said
239 pounds whatever but I mean I know
I'm being a guru but I mean right if
that's what 6-3 239 pounds like it's a
shock to me not sure if it makes me feel
better that this doctor says that he has
no cognitive issues makes me feel worse
you have covered the man for decades yes
you you feel like you've seen it you've
seen changes I'm not a doctor but I can
see that he is not the sharp mind that
he was when I first met him with more
reaction is the author of the
best-selling book vengeance former
Speaker the house foster's contributed
Newt Gingrich let's go through this the
prepuce aw the presser yesterday I still
cannot believe what I saw you have bone
spurs too much tweeting TV you know the
one school / - is he a drug addict does
the president have dentures
does the president is he sedated does he
need sedation no president has ever had
to undergo this garbage it's funny but
it's really a sick side to this well I'm
going to say first of all there's a
historian that well he didn't do it in
the press room Abraham Lincoln was
attacked with about the same savagery
and the same viciousness as Donald Trump
but I think look I'm I'm a hawk on this
all right I think they should line up
every one of the most idiotic comments
put on YouTube and have a thumbs up and
a thumbs down and thumbs up means they
get to stay thumbs down mean kick them
out of the White House you have no
obligation as president to have
something the room will be empty
nationally convinced against you
the ROI will be empty external don't be
empty pretty close let me empty because
you go out to local you go no you go to
local TV stations and you say if
somebody would like to come and try out
being able being a White House support
let's get a whole new generation of
people who aren't jaded they're not part
of the Washington gang they don't sit
around every afternoon having a cocktail
talking about how utterly stupid Trump
is and you create a whole new generation
of reporters okay
so we've been unpeeling on this program
you've been a big part of our coverage
the the layers of the onion a lot of
progress is made we now found out
uranium one in fact has been too deep
there's been a DOJ investigation nobody
knew about for months we had an 11 count
indictment at the end of last week then
we now know that the email server
scandal where the fix was in with Comey
and struck that is now back before
Congress now the dossiers is blowing up
and next week I am told we will have
news that will shock the conscience
here's my question you have Hillary we
now know rigged the primary against
Bernie had no shot Donna Brazile
confirms it then we had her to pay for a
Russian lies and propaganda to influence
the American people and bring that
election then she had called me instruct
because they so wanted her they rigged
the investigation they have it an
exoneration before an investigation with
all of what we just talked about in the
media there's very few of us discussing
this I don't mind being out on a limb
I've done it my whole career but now it
matters because the Constitution's in
play your reaction well I agree and it's
very parallel to what they did yesterday
about the health question how can the
Washington Post or the New York Times
get up in the morning and look at
themselves and not cover this I mean
there's there's something really that
that's almost pathological because as
you're pointing out week after week more
and more things are coming out it's not
just hearsay it's not just investigative
reporting as you pointed out and an 11
count indictment and frankly because I
had talked to you earlier today I talked
to some business people a while ago who
said to me oh well how do how do you
think all of this is going to play out
and they clearly were thinking only of
Trump and I said well I think the 11
count indictment on uranium one probably
doesn't bode well for Hillary they knew
nothing about
that had that there was shocked that it
occurred and I think you begin to see
the pieces come together and what I
think is only going to be an
unbelievably big scandal and makes me
feel that the defeat of Hillary even
more important than electing Trump
defeating Hillary so the corruption
couldn't go on and not be noticed
because they oh it's under the rug and I
really I agree with you wholeheartedly
but I really believe she's in deep
trouble well clearly she's in trouble
I think the foundation is in trouble but
I think frankly commis in trouble I
think you know you ninety-eight percent
of the FBI are honorable hard-working
serious people agree but at the very top
they had a lair who really had been
corrupted and didn't even realize how
corrupt they had become all right Mr
Speaker always good to see you